thousands of people are still without
power this morning after a deadly storm
system swept across the country power
lines and trees were knocked down and
homes destroyed in parts of the South
Midwest and Northeast at least a dozen
people were killed
Omar Villafranca is in Haughton
Louisiana where a couple died in a
trailer home
Omar what does the damage look like
there well good morning this is what
some of the damage looks like this is
all that's left of a home that was hit
by a tornado with 135 mile-per-hour
winds you can't even tell which room is
which and matter of fact the foundation
is about 50 yards that way now this
storm hit in the middle of the night
the couple here they didn't make it now
the family is allowing us to be here to
show the damage and like many families
across the South this morning they're
picking up the pieces my camera was
shaking and stuff but all I could do was
pray Glenn Jones says he feels blessed
to be alive after his neighbor's in
Haughton Louisiana were killed over the
weekend when a tornado demolished their
home in nearby oil city a man in his bed
was crushed to death by a tree that fell
on his home Saturday my word Ahmadi
students at Benton middle school won't
be in class today after part of the roof
was ripped off firefighters found water
in some of the classrooms in South
Carolina classes were canceled for
students in Kershaw County Schools a
tornado damaged buses and buildings that
leaders say will take days to repair
three people are confirmed dead after a
tornado hit a community in Pickens
County Alabama Saturday the guy found
his name with Tyrone Spain and the older
couple here was missing mr. Burnett
and I thought both of them in the field
behind the house dollar three when I
speak the system also brought heavy rain
and wind to the Midwest several
businesses in Missouri were reduced to
rubble in Wisconsin high winds and waves
pounded Milwaukee's lakefront there is a
tremendous amount of damage wind snow
sleet ice and rain knocked out power to
thousands across Michigan I'm trying to
keep the house I'm going down to 40
degrees
is 52 right now and in the Northeast
crews work to restore electricity after
freezing rain coated trees and downed
power lines in Vermont this tornado here
in Louisiana left a path of destruction
almost 25 miles long it's also causing a
problem with air travel but the flights
have already been canceled so if you are
traveling today down here in the south
it's probably a good idea to check with
your carrier and meteorologists say
there could be another storm on the way
this week Gayle last thing you need
thank you very much Omar
you